[Musique]
bonsoir le journal de tv soixante dix
huit pour faire le tour de l'actualité
locale bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
voici les titres de ce mercredi 30
septembre
le déplacement du ministre de la santé
dans les yvelines aujourd'hui olivier
ferrand était à la caisse d'allocations
familiales de versailles à lancement de
la première phase du service public des
pensions alimentaires il garantira aux
familles victimes d'impayés le bon
versement de ces pensions sans solution
à la rentrée le nom de ce forum qui se
tenait cet après midi à montigny le
bretonneux l'objectif aiguiller les
jeunes sans projet professionnel validé
ni formation
le contexte étant plus difficile cette
année avec l'épidémie de kovy 19
retour sur l'événement et premier bilan
en direct dans cette édition est à
guyancourt le dragon a fait peau neuve
l'oeuvre de victor roman datant de 1977
a été rénové déplacer un travail dans le
cadre de la rénovation du my des saules
dans la ville mais avant de développer
ses titres emmanuel macron sera dans les
yvelines vendredi le président de la
république viendra sedan dans la ville
des mureaux pour prononcer son discours
sur les dangers du séparatisme
il détaillera la feuille de route de son
plan de lutte contre l'islam politique
et le communautarisme
ce sera déjà le quatrième déplacement
depuis 2015 d'emmanuel macro aux mureaux
il était venu en tant que ministre du
candidat à la présidentielle la dernière
fois c'était en 2018 en tant que chef
d'état une visite autour de la culture
aujourd'hui c'était le ministre de la
santé olivier vers ans qui était dans
les yvelines il est venu avec le
secrétaire d'état adria un taquet
présenté à un nouveau dispositif à la
caisse d'allocations familiales des
yvelines il vise à éviter les impayés de
pension alimentaire et prévenir la
précarité un dispositif de 140 millions
d'euros lancée officiellement demain
jeudi
elle les précisions de michael et demi
d'euros et de nicolas landry deux
ministres à la caf de versailles ce
mercredi 30 septembre olivier véran
ministre des solidarités de la santé le
secrétaire d'état adrien taquet chargée
de l'enfance et des familles sont venues
présenter la première phase du service
public sur les pensions alimentaires
objectifs du dispositif éviter les
impayés prévenir la précarité des
familles d'abord elle est capable de
vous verser une allocation d'environ 116
euros par mois pour vous permettre déjà
de tenir en attendant que ce service
public ait prélevé directement sur les
ressources du conjoint qui n'a pas
verser la pension alimentaire
ce qu'il vous doit de manière à vous le
verset y compris d'ailleurs en regardant
jusqu'à deux ans en arrière
ainsi il n'y aura plus demain de pension
alimentaire non versée
ce dispositif lancé ce 1er octobre est
attendue par les dizaines de familles
yvelinois c'est le cas pour jolie fille
serio lee mère de quatre enfants
originaire de monti le bretonneux
séparés depuis quatre ans ça facilite
énormément de choses énormément démarche
parce que c'est vrai que c'est pas
évident malgré les procédures
judiciaires malgré est repassé devant la
justice pour
fixez des pensions alimentaires dans les
yvelines on recense plus de trente neuf
mille familles monoparentales
actuellement 850 de procédure de
recouvrement pour impayés de pension
alimentaire sont ouvertes
un déplacement dans le contexte de la
crise épidémique avec des chiffres du
cor vite 19 qui sont en forte hausse le
ministre n'a pas voulu s'exprimer sur le
sujet car une conférence de presse est
prévue demain
paris pourrait d'ailleurs bientôt passer
en rouge écarlate c'est à dire en zone
d' alerte maximale avec des mesures
encore plus restrictive à l'instar de la
guadeloupe et de l'agglomération
d'aix-marseille et ce en raison de
dernières données qui sont alarmantes
le coc u19 qui a des conséquences
également sur la bonne tenue des classes
depuis vendredi l'école élémentaire
notre dame des oiseaux est fermé à
verneuil-sur-seine 760 élèves en tout
sont donc désormais contraints de rester
chez eux
elle a raison une mesure de précaution
prise par la rs suite à la suspicion
d'un cas positifs chez un professeur si
le protocole a été assouplie en cas de
positivité chez un élève
le flou demeure pour l'heure pour les
enseignants l'école restera fermée au
moins jusqu'au 5 octobre
ce mercredi après midi la ville de
montigny le bretonneux organisait le
premier forum sans solution à la rentrée
un événement en partenariat avec yveline
information jeunesse
au programme rencontres avec des
professionnels offre de contrat et de
formation pour les jeunes sur place
justin brasier accompagner les jeunes
sans projet c'est ce que propose le
forum sans solution à la rentrée un
événement organisé à montigny le
bretonneux
il permet aux jeunes de rencontrer des
professionnels de la formation et de
l'emploi
l'objectif de ce forum il est de pouvoir
faire bénéficier les jeunes du bassin
saint quentin
versailles 2 d'offres d'emploi d'offres
de contrats d'apprentissage de formation
et
qu'ils puissent effectivement un moment
donné s'orienter et
et qu'on puisse leur donner voilà des
outils est aussi vraiment des offres
d'emploi pour pouvoir avancer
suite à cette crise qui a été vraiment
très très très très dur quarante deux
exposants étaient présents sur place
pour l'occasion
objectif proposer aux jeunes service
civique emploi ou encore formation
remplir nos classes qui ne sont pas
pleines voilà pour
à la fois nous ça nous permet de les
remplir et puis ça permet de trouver des
solutions pour les jeunes qui n'en n'ont
pas et qui cherche encore des places
dans ces formations là ils peuvent se
renseigner prendre contact et puis
s'inscrire 200 jeunes entre 15 et 20 ans
étaient attendus ils sont venus pour
candidater ou encore se renseigner pour
leurs projets je cherche un emploi ou un
stage en librairie et
j'espère grâce aux organismes comme pôle
emploi ce cahier emploi et la mission
locale au fuji inscrits pourront
peut-être m'aider en tout cas à trouver
un travail voulant stage je me suis
essentiellement renseigner auprès de ces
organismes et à plusieurs ya plein de
gens accessibles qui sont là pour
répondre à toutes nos questions
notamment bank sky emploi si j'ai bien
compris qui est prêt qu'il ya plein de
choses à proposer donc avoir pour les
recontacter et s'inscrire sur l'or sur
leur site un autre forum sera organisé
le mercredi 7 octobre
il se déroulera à la maison des
associations d'aubergenville est avec
nous depuis ce forum qui est désormais
terminée laurence cousin bonsoir vous
êtes la directrice d'yveline information
jeunesse c'est l'une des structures
organisatrices de cet événement déjà un
premier bilan est ce que l'après midi a
été concluante
oui je pense qu on est tous satisfaits
que ce soit le réseau information
jeunesse comme les partenaires présents
il y avait plus de 45 stands et puis on
a reçu plus de 150 jeunes cet après midi
donc après à l'heure des bilans a sonné
puisqu'on a des questionnaires de
satisfaction donc dès ce sera
effectivement qu'ils aient trouvé une
solution juste et l objectif de cet
après midi que ce soit en formation en
emploi ou une sur un dispositif
d'engagement 150 jeunes dont ils étaient
nombreux ces jeunes aujourd'hui au
gymnase pierre de coubertin est ce qu'on
peut expliquer voilà cette forte
présence des jeunes avec aussi ce
paramètre collier de 19 cette année qui
a peut-être rendu les entreprises plus
réfractaires à embaucher est ce que
c'est c'est plus difficile cette année
pour les jeunes en fait on retrouve déjà
n'a peut-être plus fragilisées qui
pendant ce confinement non pas justement
était accompagné n'ont pas pu rencontrer
en direct les entreprises ou les écoles
et donc là le fait de faire un dating
c'était ça l'idée
ça permet justement de trouver la
solution en temps réel si je puis dire
les a tapé toute la différence
alors vous l'avez dit 45 stands étaient
proposés sur place avec 35 recruteurs
pour des alternances des emplois des
stages et du service civique est ce
qu'il a été aussi facile de convaincre
ses recruteurs de participer à ce forum
est ce que malgré le contexte les
entreprises
les organismes de formation aussi ont
des besoins en recrutement a
complètement là franchement on n'avait
même pas assez de stands au vu des
conditions sanitaires qu'on devait
respecter bien entendu donc on a dû
refuser des places 1 donc effectivement
il ya encore pas mal d'opportunités et
donc beaucoup de demandes et qu'on n'a
pas pu forcément satisfaire il y avait
aussi un pôle information et
accompagnement avec toutes les
structures d'information jeunesse des
environs dont yvelines bien sûr
information jeunesse
un jeune qui se retrouve aujourd'hui
dans cette situation sans avoir de
projets validés pas de formation quel
accompagnement vous pouvez lui proposer
c'est vrai qu'on a des structures de
proximité 28 structures information
jeunesse sûr de rien que sur le
département des yvelines
donc c'est de se rapprocher d'un
informateur jeunesse qui va
l'accompagner selon ce problématique
soit vers pôle emploi la mission locale
soit vers un cio enfin on a le réseau de
partenaires et donc on fait le lien et
on accompagne qu'on écoute le jeune pour
trouver la solution qui va qui va lui
correspondra alors on imagine tu en as
de multiples mais quelle solution
concrètement peuvent s'offrir
aujourd'hui aux jeunes un jeune sans
projet aba un jeune sans projet en fait
l'idée c'est pas forcément de trouver
des solutions tout prix je vois la
lumière je rentre non c'est de voir ce
qu'elle et son projet professionnel pour
être cohérent fou que le jaune il
travaille son projet professionnel et à
partir de là on va l'accompagner dans
son projet on connaît tous les
dispositifs on connaît les porteurs de
ces dispositifs et on va faire du relais
vers ces structures de pardon il y avait
de nombreuses par exemple écoles en
alternance qui avait encore des places
et qui avaient des recruteurs
donc l'idée c'est de trouver la bonne le
bon jeune qui va correspondre pourra
effectivement qu'ils puissent intégrer
la formation avec l'employeur puisse
avoir le bon match on a compris à
l'horrible in information jeunesse est
aussi un centre ressource europe qui
informe les jeunes sur les possibilités
de partir étudier à l'étranger
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut toujours
partir à l'étranger au vu du contexte
est-ce que c'est toujours possible
oui c'est toujours possible après
effectivement on va les renseigner selon
le pays selon la destination les
contraintes sont plus ou moins
différents donc il faut bien sûr
respecter les normes de chaque pays et
puis alors il ya beaucoup moins de
peut-être deux
jobs d'offres d'emploi au vu du contexte
économique mondial
par contre là notamment avec le club
teli il se trouve qu'il ya énormément
par contre de propositions de stage donc
les jeunes qui voudraient partir en
stage à l'international on a un code
partenaires et donc on peut leur donner
des offres de divers et varié selon les
pays qui les intéressent donc on est en
veille un sur tout tout est toutes ces
opportunités là puisqu'on est labellisé
euros desk
alors le 7 octobre prochain du côté de
d'aubergenville y aura un autre
événement on part sur le même format
d'événements exactement le même format
avec notre réseau information jeunesse
du nord evelyne donc à auberge
accueillis par aubergenville avec mantes
la jolie dans ta ville l'imepo de
gargenville je vais en oublier
mais voilà et tous les partenaires aussi
locaux donc sur le même format formation
formation en alternance emploi et
engagement et ce sera le 7 octobre du
côté de la maison des associations
d'aubergenville de 14h à 17h merci
laurence cousin d'avoir été avec nous
tout à fait merci à vous et vous avez un
concept vous attend directrice d'une
information jeunesse et merci également
à maripa notera pour les moyens
techniques
un mode économie avec ce chiffre 90% la
chute vertigineuse du secteur de
l'automobile pendant le confinement pour
bmw france dont le siège est à montigny
le bretonneux même constat même si
depuis les prises de commandes sont en
augmentation nicolas landry a fait le
point avec le président du directoire de
la marque automobile en france
[Musique]
globalement l'automobile a fait un moins
90% pendant le pendant la période de
confinement pur
en revanche au moment de la reprise et
là je vous parlais en prises de
commandes pas en immatriculations mais
globalement sur le mois de juin on a
fait un + 78 70 % par rapport à l'année
dernière en bmw sur le mois de juin
uniquement en milieu on a doublé les
chiffres sur le mois de juin mois de
juillet on a fait respectivement 1 + 36
% et 1 + 50 % au niveau bmw motorrad en
commandes depuis le début de l'année
nous avions à fin juin déjà rattraper le
retard donc on était étale et sur mini
on a rattrapé par dont l'aura tard à fin
août pour bmw group france très
clairement mais j'aimerais souligner la
résilience la réactivité la flexibilité
lagides et l'agilité pardon des
collaborateurs français et de l'ensemble
des équipes du réseau bmw de nos
partenaires et il faut savoir que nous
avions déjà en terme logistique en
termes de méthodes de travail
nous avions signé un accord de
télétravail depuis deux ans le fait
d'être hantée et travaille en permanence
et le fait de de travailler à distance
alors qu'au contraire nous avons
déménagé pour travailler ensemble et
renforcer les synergies
ça a été un chamboulement mais très
clairement les équipes ont réagi de
manière très positive et on sait que de
toute façon les nouvelles méthodes de
travail sont à implémenter
ça a été un accélérateur un accélérateur
dans la relation avec les clients aussi
le digital a très largement c'est très
largement développée
pour être complètement transparent avec
vous j'étais confiant sur la reprise
j'étais plus inquiet pour l'automne et
avant l'été ça s'est confirmé la reprise
a été bonne aujourd'hui les chiffres
prouvent que l'activité est là nous
pouvons être confiants il faut se méfier
des plans sociaux il ya des annonces qui
ont été encore faite hier et aujourd'hui
donc il faut regarder comment comment ça
va se passer
autre groupe automobile qui a souffert
de la crise renault qui prévoit un large
plan d'économies de 2 milliards d'euros
sur trois ans il a été présenté ce mardi
en comité social et économique central
un plan rejeté par les quatre syndicats
du groupe de la marque au losange
renault prévoit la fermeture de son site
de choisy-le-roi dans le val-de-marne et
le transfert de l'activité de recyclage
de moteurs à flins-sur-seine d'ici à
2024 par conséquent l assemblage des
véhicules sera totalement arrêtée à
l'usiné blinoise les syndicats craignent
que le site qui emploie 4000 personnes
doivent faire face à une réduction
d'effectifs un groupe de réflexion
paritaire est prévue demain jeudi
culture et cette nouvelle jeunesse pour
le dragon de victor roman l'oeuvre
située à guyancourt a été restaurée et
déplacé à l'entrée de la roseraie anne
marie do datant de 1977 elle était à
traiter son socle refait une rénovation
qui s'inscrit dans le cadre de la
restauration du my des saules marie pas
neutre à l'oeuvre du dragon a fait peau
neuve
la dernière restauration datait des
années 1990 la communauté
d'agglomération et le musée de la ville
de saint quentin en yvelines inscrivent
ses travaux dans une politique globale
de restauration de son patrimoine
l'oeuvre a été replacé dans son pays
d'origine il ya une quarantaine
d'oeuvres bon on peut pas tout faire en
même temps il fallait faire des choix
alors cette oeuvre là parce qu'elle
était vraiment en mauvais état le socle
sur lequel était posée était dans un
état pitoyable
donc il fallait
il fallait la changer et en même temps
il y avait déjà cette idée de
éventuellement la faire gagner cet
emplacement ici du maïdo seule la
restauration a coûté environ 12000 euros
les travaux du dragon ont eu lieu
pendant le confinement et ont duré deux
semaines
les difficultés enlevez les couches de
vernis teintées et les traces de
vandalisme sur l'oeuvre de 500 kg
c'était une intervention qui était
intéressante puisque il y avait quand
même des couches de surface auquel on
n'était pas habitué assez agréable
puisque dans le contexte du confinement
on a eu le temps de consacrer tout le
temps qu'il fallait à la réflexion et à
l'identification des problématiques
après c'est une restauration qui est
quand même assez classique en fait dans
les opérations n'est souvent sur des
bronzes comme ça sur des opérations de
nettoyage cirage retouches dans le
courant de l'année prochaine une
deuxième phase de restauration du mail
des sols est prévu notamment concernant
les oeuvres
le letton et la table des géants le
septième art à présent comme chaque
mercredi le programme des salles du
territoire ce soir c'est l'ubs beaucamp
dû signer cet élan cours qui se prête à
l'exercice
c'est au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude alors cette semaine au ciné 7
mai dans plein d'autres salles en france
on va essayer de se faire un petit peu
de bien ces temps on va dire légèrement
morose et on va partir avec antoinette
dans les cévennes donc c'est un long
métrage de caroline signal qui est un
très bonne surprise en cette rentrée
dans les cinémas assez morose puisque
plein de films vous le savez
probablement été déprogrammé notamment
des gros films américains et c'est un
film à essai français donc avec laure
calamy qui est une jeune actrice qui
monte qui monte qui monte
benjamin lavernhe qui est un comédien
que vous avez déjà vu
dans plusieurs films qui est excellent
notamment dans le sens de la fête c'est
celui qui joue le marié et voilà est
donc en toile aide va partir sur les
traces de benjamin donc qui n est autre
qu son amant dans le film mais qui ne
peut plus partir au dernier moment en
vacances avec elle pour essayer de le
retrouver dans les magnifiques cévennes
que vous allez travers traverser avec
elle accompagné d'un âne donc très joli
film à découvrir dans nos salles cette
semaine
[Musique]
et puis il était de passage dans les
yvelines week-end dernier l'acteur
pierre richard est venu dédicacer les
bouteilles de vin de son domaine c'était
dans une épicerie fine de magny les
hameaux
eléonore sinoquet célia gars de 100 go
françois pignon ou encore le grand blond
pierre richard est plutôt connue comme
vedettes connues du cinéma français mais
c'est en tant que vigneron qui était
présent à magny les hameaux samedi 26
septembre
il est venu dédicacer ses bouteilles de
vin du domaine de l'évêque situé dans le
languedoc dont il est propriétaire
depuis 1986 je ne les place importante
dans ma vie elle cinéma évidemment
peut-être numéro un quand même mais
j'ai une deuxième passion une deuxième
un intérêt pour le vin parce que ça
finalement c'est un peu comme le cinéma
l'objectif du cinéma ou du vin c'est
donner du plaisir à des gens mais
ferrero les émouvoir enfin je dis pas
que le vin pour le faire les fait rire
encore qu'après la deuxième bouteille on
commence à l'école et l'acteur a fait
des émules
ils sont venus nombreux faire dédicacer
leurs bouteilles et chacun avait sa
petite raison je suis pas une grande
amatrice de vin évidemment mais c'est
surtout pour d'acteurs parce que j'adore
pierre richard et moi j'aime le vin
j'aime la gastronomie donc voilà donc
forcément ça m'arrivait de goûter ces
vins je tombais amoureuse certains
écrivent et je suis venu chercher près
de 600 bouteilles pendant le confinement
et plus de 1800 en une journée à magny
les hameaux le vin de pierre richard a
su convaincre les papilles dans un
instant sur tv 78 nouveau numéro du 7-8
société s'est présentée par vous mélanie
poquet bonsoir mon sort
de quelles thématiques va parler
d'émissions ce soir mais le thème de ce
soir c'est les impacts de lakovic 19 sur
les associations avec mes invités on va
échanger sur les événements reportés
voire annulés sur des saisons sportives
blanches ou des besoins dead toujours
présents selon une enquête 89% des
associations et affirmé avoir eu des
difficultés des difficultés dans leurs
activités de bénévolat seront présents
ce soir françoise de ses deux salles de
l'air présidente de l'association halima
sauce franco carpentier le président des
cougars de montigny-le-bretonneux et
pascal rodier le secrétaire général de
la fédération yvelinoise du secours
populaire le 7 8 sociétés c'est dans un
instant sur tv soixante dix huit rendez
vous à partir de 18h30 avant de vous
laisser vous avez peut-être entendu ce
bruit est d'explosions à la mi journée
il a été ressenti dans une grande partie
de l'île de france notamment dans les
yvelines
rassurez-vous la préfecture de police de
paris l'a confirmé dans un tweet il
s'agissait d'un avion de chasse qui a
franchi le mur du son
le rafale intervenait depuis la base de
saint-dizier en haute-marne pour porter
assistance à un aéronef en perte de
contact radio à l'est de paris
un bruit qui a laissé libre cours aux
rumeurs les plus folles sur les réseaux
sociaux
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]